you know ladies and gentlemen in past
programs here and on radio and elsewhere
i've pushed back against the putin wing
of the republican party i've pushed back
against the putin wing of the media the
appeasement of the executive branch and
the president of the united states
are truly lousy generals at the pentagon
and others it was abundantly clear to me
that when vladimir putin had almost 200
000 of his men lined up on the borders
with ukraine he intended to invade that
country
people raised out about that now that
didn't make any sense did it 500 tanks
200 000 soldiers god knows what else
he intended to invade that was the time
and even before that for this
administration
to arm up the ukrainians
not three four five weeks later not
three four five weeks later we all knew
after the disaster that was afghanistan
and the surrender by this administration
what was coming
we all knew when biden was appeasing
putin in every possible way whether it
was a pipeline or or nuclear deal and so
forth we all knew that this day would
come
we all know that communist china and xi
another psychopath genocidal maniac has
every intention of invading taiwan he's
also destroyed hong kong
we all knew that in tehran
the islamic regime there the fanatical
dangerous neo-nazi regime in tehran
is going to continue to build nukes to
look and attack israel
its gulf arab neighbors and yes even the
united states of america
if we knew this how is it that biden
didn't know it
how is it that the secretary of state
and secretary and defense didn't know it
well i suggest they knew it but they are
weak
and pathetic
now what
well
people are wanting putin to go ahead and
decide what the battlefield should look
like he threatens nuclear weapons they
shake
he threatens other weapons they shake
now ladies and gentlemen as i've said
before the old soviet union had nuclear
weapons russia has had nuclear weapons
for half a century
we have nuclear weapons too
we cannot allow nuclear blackmail to
determine what the fate of the world's
going to look like or what the fate of
the united states is going to look like
putin is not going to use nuclear
weapons certainly not now how do i know
that am i nostradamus no it's common
sense
if he wanted to use nuclear weapons he'd
use them why would he use nuclear
weapons in response to mig-29s old jets
25 or 30 of them delivered to the
ukrainians
well because it might stalemate what we
were just told by our defense department
told by our white house and all the
phony experts on tv that it wouldn't
make a difference
so if it doesn't make a difference then
why would putin go to to level one and
use nuclear weapons in response to
mig-29s he wouldn't
that's why furthermore
xi
we need to understand that we are more
powerful than china right now no thanks
to this administration but prior
administrations we're economically more
powerful militarily more powerful and
it's important that we stay that way
even though we're sliding as a result
particularly of this administration and
the obama administration
we need to muscle up our military now
not with a few billion dollars but with
a special manhattan life project not to
go to war but to prevent war to make
sure we are the most muscular military
on the face of the earth no matter how
many enemies we are facing that is a
deterrence that is a response that is
peace through strength as reagan put it
and as trump would put it as well
then we have north korea north korea was
in a box under trump look at it now now
it wants to fire its brand new shiny
icbm that'll show us right but even more
concerning right now is iran
this administration has appointed putin
for all intents and purposes to
negotiate on our behalf with the regime
in tehran that keeps talking about death
to america death to america
now they already fired ballistic
missiles at our consulate what's the
response of our government well they
didn't mean to hit our consulate
you know the enemy hears this stuff the
enemy sees this stuff
what will happen if iran gets nukes well
what's happened with putin and nukes
he's been waving them around he's been
blackmailing us he's trying to control
the battlefield right by threatening us
you hear analysts and others say oh we
got to worry about this what do you
think of ronald do
iran unleashes hezbollah against israel
if hollande topples topples the
government in egypt or saudi arabia well
we can't do anything because iran has
nukes
or all over the world iran can make
threats on behalf of its ideology and
its fundamentalism this has to be
stopped and yet the blind administration
through putin
is negotiating a deal that's weaker than
the deal in 2015. it will give
tens of billions of dollars to the
iranian regime without restriction it
will ensure that they have nuclear
weapons
placed on icbms intercontinental
ballistic missiles that can reach any
corner of the earth
it's going to ensure that terrorists who
right now
are on terrorist watch lists will be
removed they're even talking about the
republican guard the republican guard
that shot those missiles at our
consulate the republican guard
that has created all these casualties
with american soldiers you see tunnel to
towers you see wounded soldiers many of
those people
have lost limbs
have brain injuries as a result of what
the iranian republican guard and other
terrorist organizations have done ladies
and gentlemen
joe biden is ungoing is going to unleash
a nuclear
competition
where third world countries
will have nuclear weapons and it will be
easier and easier to get and harder and
harder to control that might even wind
up in the hands of
of terrorist organizations
if we do not put an end to this
peace through strength not peace through
appeasement or stupidity
because that's where we are right now
and this iran thing is not getting the
attention that it deserves
remember james carafano was on here a
couple of weeks ago the expert from
heritage foundation and he served as the
as a lieutenant colonel for 25 years in
the united states army is a brilliant
brilliant man
he gives advice to a lot of
organizations and so forth and he said
you cannot bifurcate russia from china
or china from
iran and i call this the access of evil
they're all working together they're all
trying to backstop each other if one
runs out of oil the other tries to
assist if one needs financial assistance
the other tries to assist you better
believe they're colluding and why
wouldn't they particularly with a
feckless president of the sort that we
have
so it's very important that we the
american people despite the the mostly
ignorance mostly ignorant part of the
media here
uh mostly the inattention of the media
here that we understand what's going on
in iran
and that's why i wanted to bring on
former prime minister of israel benjamin
netanyahu there's nobody better
to also discuss further russia and these
relationships with these other countries
and what we are doing in ukraine
with congressman michael waltz
we'll be right back hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else